the big thing though is the the drones
all these jerk-offs that just buy it
yeah there's Jones all over the place
yeah I think so
I was in my backyard and saw one hover
above me the other day a man was clearly
looking down and yeah it's weird I don't
like there was somebody on the other
side who was no yeah when it starts to
water that's swim you know this jacket
it just [ __ ] rake those leaves you
pack and fast at breakfast by your old
gardener man checking in on you yeah try
this here you really get you crated in
the truck are you a technology guy Jay
no I don't know I hate I hate it I want
my phone to do I don't want anything my
next car a car I own right now no GPS
none of that next one I want no GPS none
of that what are you in the mob no I
just want I like a simpler time we were
talking about today on my podcast
that's the crap he's podcasts on all
things comedy every - no I just want to
shout out to this one guy he's got a
drone flying with he's watching that
yeah talking that Boston accent Jay he
likes the hey I missed that stuff I
missed it like we were talking with Mike
Costner and he had snuck into a Beastie
Boys concert and hopped two fences and
got on stage
into the green room and he's like the
only reason I was there is cuz got to
separate from his buddies and old you
know you can't get to separate from
anyone now just like where are you drop
a pin and boom I missed the times you
know no cell phones no cream I mean no
sirenix on the other day and they go to
me what's your cell if they goes this
your cell phone number and yeah that's
the one we have a record one two three
four five six seven eight nine I'm like
yes it is you know cuz I was gonna pull
[ __ ] thing right it wasn't that bad but
was a good phony one and then they go we
need a second number I go I don't have a
second number that's all you have well
can you wait actually say wellpoint what
about your parents and I looked at him I
go I'm not giving you my parents phone
number and she actually laughed and she
goes you got to give me something so I'm
like 9 1 7
eight two eight one two three four this
she's like that came up as an invalid
number give me another number
oh well we did this on the first podcast
but everybody three two three six six
eight zero nine eight six that's three
two through we're all gonna try to use
the same number the same thing
everything grocery store and try try to
track us yeah well it's one of my old
numbers from but we're all gonna like
collectively all podcast listeners
should it's three two three so what's it
gonna do oh boy buying groceries and
[ __ ] multiple states at the same time
like they won't [ __ ] up the grid all
credit for it Al's like Ralph's reward
card is like